bentornati a una puntata di cucina
buttata oggi hanno deciso di fare una
cosa particolare una caramella di queste
dimensioni vi dico solo che una delle
quantità della ricetta saranno 30 uova
andiamo in cucina dove ci aspetta
gianmarco li stava aspettando fare
questa ricetta avremo bisogno di 3 litri
e mezzo di latte io non so nemmeno se un
qualcosa che può far entrare 3 litri e
mezzo di latte 750 grammi di zucchero 30
tuorli questo vorrà dire che avremo così
tanti albumi da poterci fare pancake
proteici fino alla fine dei nostri tempi
che uccide racket e l'equipaggio tutto
in una botta 30 album i perché perché
non fanno niente albumi non fanno niente
ai giudici tuorli tuorli questa colpa di
luigi l'uomo pur dire il pc è infine
hanno bisogno di 100 grammi di gelatina
che non è proprio un alimento di quelli
che ti dice che bello magari che bello
sì perché lo schiaffetto album in one
dire dare io sì che quando si ha fatto
dire ai ragazzi ma perché ogni volta
come cerca di fare una cosa
semplicissima di louboutin a dovete fare
il salto dell'hamburger lo schiaffo del
locale come se fossero chiappone mani
pulite utilizzare una tecnica e se
dovevo schiaffeggiarlo mani pulite
intenzioni sporche secondo la ricetta di
vista che ormai allenato come si fa
questo tipo ne da schiaffeggiare vi
servirà un aiutante sì grazie a youtube
c'è mai lo chef mario mairano zucchero
100 g un bicchiere gentilmente chef
mario chef mario un bicchiere ma viste
cioè ancora il caffè nel sì
non ho mai tolto cioè non ho mai avuti e
di settimane che gli quale rotonda
toccava fare un esame hccp 20 ml d'acqua
come si vedono 30 nella città diretta g
di acqua aria mo e vero noi nipote
abbiamo cercato di fare un qualsiasi
cosa simile a carla pathos chi guarda
che è quello della burrobirra della
buona uscendo fare tutto a me sembrano
trarre su tutti devono più a una
trattativa di acciaio è un poeta ferma
personaggio da enrico gianni ti prendi
intanto lui sei alto di quelli a destra
questo è certo che non ci arrivo tu
forse sì ti sdrai servita a che si
sdraia che arriva sicuro de vence
[Musica]
oppure cominciato a fare le uova o nord
ha mai visto però fermati fermati ha
fermati ma che stai facendo niente non
so quello che è fermati
questo è un po tipo acqua nella vasca si
stavo per dire lo stesso che sta
succedendo sembra nibili mai fallito
allora riproviamoci zucchero che come
l'acqua di più secondo voi lo sa il
pubblico c'è ma certo ma c'era zafferano
dice proprio di metter c'era pochissimo
tele fatto diventa un minerale
ritroviamoci una seconda volta pensa a
bollire cerbo capiamo perché non puoi
cominciare a lavorare delle uova sta
cominciando a friggere
lei risvegliato un sembra di sì la fase
prima del fallimento questa 30
come ci si sente che ha fatto se un uomo
bussi con questo e questo spero pulcini
0 di apollo accusato il caramello non
etico rosso perché bianco questo se ci
mettete nuovamente acqua fredda e amate
non ce la mettiamo in genio no se non ce
la mettiamo si secca non possiamo
chiamare giulia giulia est di nuovo
chiede una cosa per il caramello e crème
caramel ma non viene giulia sto
impazzendo alba va giù paribas va giù lo
stiamo facendo in padella però non si
colora mai posso dire che c'è qualcosa
qualcosa sì ma non va bene ragazzi sa
proprio niente all'oscuro bello se lo
chiede come fa il caramello abbiamo
fatto cioni mai fatto capire tutto
grazie bisogna avere pazienza
queste sono le mie palle in questo
momento oddio questo è il caramello sì
ma mi stai dicendo che se vedi un attimo
di pazienza pure prima si sarebbe dire
c'è la fase successiva era quella se ti
piace strizzare delle uova
tieni no no ragazzi buttatele giugno e
io sto versando mai ottimo lavoro
comunque bisogna avere pazienza non
cambierà quello lo devi lascia così a
marcino lasciamo così intanto a marcire
mentre velocemente dobbiamo fare il
resto e inizia a mettere tre litri e
mezzo di latte qua dentro se non entrano
qua 54
e mezzo manca mezzo litro voglio farlo
riscaldarvi come quest'anno ragazzi
questi qua per prepararli bisogna acqua
fredda
questa gelatina in fogli per chi non lo
conoscesse questi qui diventeranno
gelatinosi grazie all'acqua fredda ci
sono delle alghe e la porcheria
tutto questo zucchero 750 grammi 30
tuorli insieme ai 750 grammi di zucchero
a questo fai così strizzi e tutti dentro
frattempo il attrezzata tutta la
tristezza strizza bene senza paura jamil
ti prego fai tu questa non è bello
vigoroso vai vai
mamma mia ci siamo ci siamo c'è sempre
mamma mia
brutto proprio ok lecchiamo le cure con
la card ragazze ria del momento della
verità
perché hanno intra che cos'è l'etichetta
dello zucchero è bene scegliere c'è la
base scura li perfetto per aspettare
devo mettere in frigo refrigeri
bisognerebbe mai mettere cose calde in
in frigo però far apparire la recezione
perché si rovinano i feriti ok e ci
vediamo domani ci vediamo domani ci
vediamo domani insieme ci vediamo domani
ci vediamo domani quando ci vediamo
domani e dopodomani cosa facciamo niente
signori benvenuti al giorno dopo è
arrivato il momento di vedere che cosa
c'è dentro quel frigo ora le cose sono
due o è tenuto perfettamente oppure è
venuto una merda oppure sembra che
secondo perfettamente la realtà con una
merda pure sembra non dover fettamente
quindi sono quattro
[Risate]
non so allora non ci troviamo questa
cosa qui facciamo il primo step si si oh
dio signoria per credere si stacca
proverei a sto punto a far fare un
lavoro alla forze gravità non sa se
certo bravo ha fatto di rigirare in
questo signorino un po di paura nel
senso che non so come rigirarlo quindi
io direi così l'idea il salto all idea
da così a sopravvivere da così poco
sopra la mia testa perché mamma non ho
bisogno di gianni anonomi vedere una
manca non ho da davanti davanti non
sovrani a testa prima che gireremo
naturalmente questa cosa intanto
iscritte via questo canale mettete un
pollice in su per il perché molto
probabilmente i nostri pollici saranno
impegnati a lavare per terra ma più
facile di quello che sembra vada così tu
mi dai una mano a fare questo ci sei è
una cinema e della somma 3 2 1 ok ok
abbiamo rigirato non si è staccato col
dio quando si sta staccando no ma che è
successo qualcosa di inquietante non
hanno poi fare così perché è perché
adesso ha fatto di effetto ventosa ha
davvero è certo il budino è sceso e ha
barca non toccare ecco nella trasferta
vai dai ragazzi parliamone è favoloso
stupendo c'è molto bello guarda che puoi
fare è bellissimo grazie allora sì lei
sono molto entusiasta di questa cosa ti
ti ti ti ti sei molto bravo realtà ad
attivare
si sta per indurre il piatto no non ho
già vinto bene ok basta accusa perché
porti le mangiamo così le come lo mangio
in tanti ma chi è gay di due ma scusa è
fermo ma è molto più bello vedere il
taglio del budino mattina c'è ora
chiamiamo tutta la famiglia per mangiare
questo gigantesco budino live rotto è
una nota molto triste se ne sa solo di
nuovo c'è una mail di vino è buono ma a
me non piacciono le cose però è fatto e
mourinho erice brutto a me queste cose
piacciono
massa 7 piaccia della stampa gnam burino
intero sportivo caramello quindi
possiamo dire
missione riuscita riuscisse di
offrissero 5.000 euro
severo mangereste in due questo caso vi
offre gratis il caramello di sette tutto
c'è pure una nota a marostica di
bruciato
c'è una roba si no
daiwa uso il sinistro ma che infittiti
bagnate per che cosa ci sta il magna
quelle tre volte ripetuto e lo sapevi
aree salutarmi e come sempre il derby un
appuntamento così non buttata ora
prossima domenica sempre a mezzogiorno
ciao